con la llegada del verano los ciudadanos
de la unión europea pronto podrán
empezar a empacar sus maletas luego de
cuatro rondas de negociaciones los
estados miembros acordaron permitir de
nuevo los viajes los europeos podrán
solicitar el llamado certificado digital
de kobe que les permitirá moverse
libremente dentro del bloque a partir
del primero de julio
si usted está vacunado en un estado
miembro de la unión europea entonces el
sistema de salud de su país le
proporcionará un certificado esa es la
nueva regla de juego y lo que el nuevo
documento hará el documento cubrirá a
cualquier persona que esté vacunada
contra el coronavirus que tenga una
prueba pcr negativa o que se haya
recuperado recientemente de la
enfermedad paralelamente a partir del 24
de mayo españa permitirá la entrada a
turistas de países extracomunitarios con
bajo riesgo de contagio por coronavirus
y sin prueba pcr negativa y el 7 de
junio se permitirá la entrada solo a
aquellos que ya estén vacunados gran
bretaña el mercado más grande de españa
para el turismo se incluirá en la lista
también australia nueva zelanda e israel
desde el próximo lunes españa estará
encantada encantadísima de acoger a
todos los turistas británicos y del
resto de países que acabo de mencionar
otros países como grecia ya reactivaron
su temporada de turismo con la esperanza
de revivir el sector para obtener el
certificado digital de kobe sólo se
aceptarán las vacunas aprobadas por la
agencia europea de medicamentos pzifer
modernas astrazéneca y jansen ahora
queda que la unión europea adopte
formalmente la medida y que el
parlamento ratifique su uso durante su
próxima sesión plenaria en junio